mesdames messieurs bon dimanche assumez
la souveraineté renouée avec le Parti
québécois et préparer la prochaine
campagne électorale de quoi alimenter
les conversations congrès du Bloc
québécois cette fin de semaine
Drummondville devant le regain de
popularité que connaît le PQ certains
militants souhaitent que le bloc précise
sa mission que la souveraineté revienne
à l'avant-plan du discours plutôt que de
se concentrer sur la défense des
intérêts du Québec à Ottawa le chef et
François Blanchette estime que l'un
n'empêche pas l'autre et pense qu'un
message articulé sur l'identité et
l'intégration pourrait permettre au bloc
de démarquer mon entretien avec le chef
du Bloc québécois et François Blanchet
je crois sincèrement qu'une nouvelle
fenêtre historique s'ouvre devant nous
je crois sincèrement que le Bloc
québécois a un rôle absolument crucial à
jouer et c'est dans l'amitié et la
fierté que le Parti québécois va tout
donner à vos côtés
et j'ai un espoir sincère que côte à
côte nous ferons naître le pays que nous
méritons tant
[Musique]
et François Blanchet merci
quoi plus de 30 ans le Québécois quelle
est la grande différence entre le bloc
dit François Blanchette et le bloc de
Lucien Bouchard
la patience
parce que on ne sait pas à quel moment
le momentum favorable à l'idée de
souveraineté va nous amener cette
majorité de députés souverainistes à
l'Assemblée nationale du Québec mais le
côté temporaire du bloc demeure le bloc
est temporaire et cessera d'avoir sa
pertinence lorsque le Québec sera
souverain mais en regard de l'histoire
30 ans c'est très peu de choses et tant
que le Québec n'est pas souverain on ne
peut pas permettre que des élus aux
fédérales de parties Canadiens
détruisent ou compromettre ce que
l'Assemblée nationale du Québec met de
l'avant ou ce que veut le Québec on
s'entend que 30 ans le temporaire de
monsieur Bouchard à l'époque c'était pas
30 ans c'était pas 30 ans parce qu'il y
avait une fenêtre à l'intérieur de
quelques années puis ça s'est
matérialisé il reste que tant que le
Québec est pas souverain je crois que le
Québec a besoin du bloc ou le bloc doit
continuer à présenter son offre au
Québec et de toute évidence jusqu'à
maintenant le Québec la reçoit
positivement
vous êtes proche de qui le blog vous
l'avez évoqué un peu tout à l'heure la
défense des intérêts du Québec les
intérêts du Québec présentement c'est la
carte qui les véhicules à l'Assemblée
nationale avec une forte majorité
vous sentez une relation de proximité
plus favorable avec qui avec le PQ avec
la carte on a une amitié naturelle avec
le Parti québécois parce que le Parti
québécois est un parti frère qu'on
fréquente depuis toujours on a des
affinités ponctuelles avec la coalition
à Québec qui a bien des égards peut
prétendre être à elle seule un consensus
de l'Assemblée nationale compte tenu de
leur très très grande majorité
évidemment on n'est plus confortable
lorsque la coalition américaine et le
Parti Québécois sont d'accord mais on a
encore régulièrement d'émotions unanime
de l'Assemblée nationale puis tous les
partis de l'Assemblée nationale à titre
d'exemple on rejeté sans équivoque la
politique d'accueillir sans même
consulter le Québec 500000 immigrants
par année à partir de 2025 l'Assemblée
nationale la rejette c'est tout le monde
à l'Assemblée nationale pour nous ça
c'est leader est-ce que le nationalisme
de la CAQ est trop timide à votre goût
pour moi comme nationaliste oui je vais
aller plus loin que que monsieur Legault
mais moi comme nationaliste qu'un parti
nationaliste avec les positions qu'on
leur connaissait et obtenu 90 sièges
dans des endroits où on pensait que ça
serait plus possible ça m'impressionne
beaucoup je trouve que c'est très
positif pour l'avenir ça veut dire que
le territoire qu'on peut où on peut
faire élire des députés que ce soit de
la carte que ce soit du bloc ou
éventuellement de qui que ce soit
d'autre qui soit résolument nationaliste
et plus grand qu'on le pensait l'appétit
vient en mangeant la prise de conscience
que le modèle du Canada n'est pas le
nôtre a bien des égards pourrait donner
le goût à des gens de reprendre cette
réflexion là moi je suis pas au monde on
va voter pour l'indépendance demain
matin je dis on va reprendre de plus en
plus activement une réflexion parce que
la question va de nouveau vous a posé
dans quelques heures
il me semble que né après année les
partis politiques le vôtre le PQ dit
cette réflexion là elle est pas morte
elle va on voit la on avoir revenir ça
se concrétise pas qu'est-ce qui pourquoi
ce serait différent cette fois-ci quand
il y a plus que le tiers d'une
population qui veut que reste vivante
pour ne pas abandonner puis lorsque
Monsieur Parisot a initié la démarche
vers le référendum de 1995 il était plus
bas qu'on ne l'ai maintenant dans les
appuis à la souveraineté alors il suffit
d'une réflexion qui doit être alimentée
nourri plus intense c'est pas la
priorité des gens à côté du barbecue au
mois de mai mais nous notre travail
c'est de garder ça actif il utilisait
les enjeux d'immigration les enjeux de
laïcité les enjeux de l'angle les enjeux
de pétrole tous les enjeux qui
différencient le Canada du Québec pour
nourrir cette réflexion là et dire aux
gens on a le droit et on a la capacité
de faire autre chose par nous-mêmes tout
en gardant des ententes cordiales saines
commerciales militaire ou autre avec le
Canada ou avec les États-Unis
congrès national
probablement le dernier avant les
élections il faut probablement
vous allez l'utiliser pour peaufiner la
mission du bloc vous avez votre
proposition vous l'appelez c'est une
proposition
qui va être votre programme officiel que
vous appelez des principes
parce qu'on voulait
en fait on voulait que les mandats
précis les ordres les directives aux
élus ou aux partis viennent des
militants et on s'est consacré à mettre
à jour définir les principes de qui nous
sommes comme formation politique et qui
nous croyons que le Québec est ou
pourrait être mais ça se traduit comment
des principes en engagement électoraux
n'importe quel dossier ou sujet qui nous
serait présenté va être géré en vertu de
ses principes là lorsque on dit par
exemple que le Québec est une terre
d'accueil probablement la plus généreuse
en Amérique en termes d'immigration mais
qu'à ça se fait avec un espèce de corpus
comme un de valeur de connaissances de
l'histoire des tops droits d'égalité et
bien sûr la langue française mais on va
appliquer ça à toutes les grilles
d'analyse nécessaire sur n'importe quel
enjeu d'immigration on le fait déjà tous
les jours on fait déjà des propositions
pratiquement tous les jours ça s'appuie
sur le principe de qui on est de ce
qu'on veut et de ce qu'on propose c'est
quoi l'enjeu qui va être la clé de vote
pour vous durant la prochaine campagne
électorale comment ça se dessine c'est
toujours assez extraordinaire parce que
tout autre chose étant égale ce qui
anime et fait encore le plus réagir les
Québécois c'est davantage qui nous
sommes que ce qu'on va faire
les enjeux identitaires de langue les
enjeux de valeur les enjeux d'égalité
les enjeux d'accueil les enjeux
d'intégration interpellent encore
davantage les Québécois que il faut se
dire beaucoup d'enjeux économiques où
les enjeux environnementaux peut-être
parce que c'est jamais réglé et les
autres éléments qui sont importants dans
un programme qu'est ce qu'on va faire
pour les années ou pour les agriculteurs
ça reste fondamental dans un programme
mais les gens en reviennent toujours sur
qui nous sommes et ça risque d'être
encore au cœur de la prochaine campagne
électorale d'autant plus que tant les
conservateurs que les libéraux
s'éloignent de ce que souhaite le Québec
et s'éloigne de leur volonté de
flirter avec le nationalisme québécois
qui a animé la dernière campagne
électorale en réélection parlons
d'élection va y en avoir une campagne il
y a deux scénarios vous allez pas former
le gouvernement ça va être un
gouvernement
potentiellement libéral ou conservateur
dans les scénarios de gouvernement
conservateurs minoritaire c'est toujours
le bloc qui se retrouve à appuyer
monsieur poignet
un peu différemment il y a des chances
significatives que le bloc détient la
balance du pouvoir après la prochaine
élection il y a des gens qui
s'inquiètent de ça chez nous parce qu'on
deviendrait responsable d'une partie de
la gestion de l'État canadien et à
l'extérieur parce qu'il serait pris en
otage par des souverainistes québécois
si le Bloc québécois se fait confier la
balance du pouvoir par les Québécois qui
vont bien voir que les intentions de
vote des conservateurs ne leur donnent
pas la perspective de faire la
différence au Québec
ils vont se dire et on va leur dire que
soit on force des changements dans les
projets de loi les budgets l'émotion qui
sont déposées on force des changements
qui sont bons pour le Québec ou soit on
refuse et quand on refuse ça passe pas
c'est extrêmement important comme
pouvoir on est capable d'imposer la
vision du Québec au gouvernement du
Canada pour contre les provinces
canadiennes mais en s'assurant qu'à
chaque fois il y a pas de recul pour le
Québec c'est sûr qu'un gouvernement
conservateur
arriverait avec des
positions qui sont profondément contre
nos valeurs que ce soit le soutien au
pétrole ou l'avortement ou la débauche
d'armes à feu mais il y aura pas la puce
du bloc et ils seront incapables d'aller
de l'avant et si c'est ça que la
démocratie décide et si les Québécois
décident de nous donner Bloc québécois
ce pouvoir là et on va en faire un usage
responsable prudent mais on va faire
usage merci beaucoup